and click on books
on august 9 1974 president nixon
resigned from office under threat of
impeachment
next book tv marks the 30th anniversary
with his 1992 appearance on book notes
the 37th president of the united states
details his book seize the moment
america's challenge in a one superpower
world
former president richard nixon in your
new book seize the moment
on page 105 you ask the question who is
the real gorbachev
who do you think the real gorbachev is
well i would say based on knowing him
having met with him twice
that is not a great deal but it is
enough to get make an appraisal and read
a lot about him
i would make these observations
first he is
a man who made a difference
therefore he will be remembered in
history
as one of the major leaders perhaps one
of the greatest leaders of the 20th
century
he is the man who also
has made it possible
for yelston his great rival
to be president of russia today without
garbage off yelston
could not have been on the scene as he
is
now how did he do that
first garbachoff is a communist
he has been and still is he is a russian
nationalist
in addition to that he's a brilliant
pragmatic politician
what happened to him and why he failed
was that he was so sincerely a communist
and a marxist that he couldn't make
the basic decision which is that which
was absolutely essential to abandon
a doctrinaire marxism to allow private
property and to go forward with economic
reforms which could match his political
reforms
he deserves credit for his political
reforms
for some free elections for some free
press
and for freedom in other areas
he failed when he did not combine that
with economic reforms with free markets
and the rest and that is why the russian
economy the soviet economy was a
disaster at the end of his tenure the
final thing i would say with regard to
him is that he is
one who became a world figure but in
becoming a world figure and dazzling the
world he lost touch with his own people
that is why i think he failed but all in
all
he will be remembered as i have
indicated in a very positive way
because he made possible what has
happened today although
i must indicate
that his reforms had the objective
not of getting rid of communism but of
saving it and then trying to save it he
lost his position
in this uh
paragraph here we talk about him you say
he is a highly intelligent sophisticated
and supremely self-confident leader with
the great ego characteristic of most
successful statesmen
what's the ego characteristic you're
talking about
by the ego characteristic i mean that
he believes sincerely that he is the man
best qualified to lead his country
and incidentally it happens that in his
case the ego went a bit too far
uh the mark in my
in my view of a great leader is one
who is so confident of his own abilities
that he's not afraid to have people who
are brighter than he is around him
garbage off except for cheverus nazi and
two or three others who eventually
deserted him
surrounded himself particularly at the
last by
second-rate people i would say
first-rate second-rate men
and as a result he didn't have the kind
of advice that he should have had he
rejected those who could have given him
the best kind of advice
but
on the other hand the ego served him
well
in that it
allowed him to reach the top
in the soviet hierarchy he couldn't have
done that unless he had had great
self-confidence how did you approach
this book i know it's all about the
world it's called seize the moment first
of all why the title
well the title comes out of
a recollection that i had of my visit to
china which incidentally took place just
20 years ago as we are sitting here
and on that occasion
i quoted
from a poem that mouse tongue
had written and a toast that i gave
there in the great hall of the people
in which he said
seize the day seize the hour
because many things urgently remain to
be done
mauser tongue was talking about seizing
the day and seizing the hour
in order to serve the interests of
communism
i feel that at the present time
we must also recognize a sense of
urgency we should seize the moment
but not
for the victory of communism but for the
victory of freedom and that is what this
book is all about communism as an idea
has been defeated all over the world
except for china and a few other smaller
countries like in vietnam laos and
cambodia
but freedom
has not yet won it has not won in the
sense that it is it has not yet proved
itself until it proves itself there's
always a chance we will revert or some
other countries will revert to an
authoritarian
leadership
the last word you wrote was september
the 11th 1991
after the coup
but before mr gorbachev left
are you
surprised at how accurate this chapter
is on i mean you make all the
predictions
well i must say that uh i feel rather
fortunate
lucky i would say and there's a lot of
luck in
politics as in anything anyplace else
although you do make your luck to an
extent
but in this instance i tried to evaluate
gorbachev and yelston and the forces
that were in play in the soviet union
based on my experience there which goes
back quite a few years as you know
but also on a trip that i took there in
march
of last year
when i met gorbachev and nelson and
frankly all of the members of the
so-called gang of four all of them
except one
who one of whom has committed suicide
and the other three are sitting in jail
at the present time
based on that trip and based on a visit
to ukraine and lithuania and other
countries i reached the conclusion that
gorbachev
even after he returned
would not last i reached the conclusion
that yeltsin was the man of the future
gorbachev was the man of the past i must
say when i submitted the manuscript to
the publishers on september the 11th
i kept wondering
by the time this book comes out will it
be overtaken by events it has not been
but i wouldn't give myself a lot of
credit
for being
so perceptive in that respect
a lot of luck was involved too
let me read you another line yeltsin's
resolute leadership of the democratic
revolution after the coup made him a
world figure and exposed his critics
in western diplomatic and media circles
as political amateurs who are you
talking about
well i i suppose i'm talking about uh
those
who
who were so impressed by style
uh i'm speaking of those who evaluated
gorbachev who was a man
who dazzled people with his intelligence
with his grace
uh
with his uh
with his reforms
uh his political reforms particularly
and who then jumped to the conclusion
that he was the only one
that the west could rely upon and that
we had to go with him going with yeltsin
would be a great mistake now who are
these people
well they are people i greatly respect
we should all greatly respect they have
studied foreign affairs they have
studied
foreign policy they have studied the
soviet union for many many years
but they have a tendency
i'm referring now to people in the
diplomatic corps i'm referring to many
columnists and others they have a
tendency
to be
overcome
by and impressed by style rather than by
substance and gorbachev had style on the
other hand yellston was one
who came across in their view
as being boorish
he drank too much he was a womanizer at
least these were some of the stories
that came out
he was one that wasn't in gorbachev's
league as so far as style is concerned
for example
i remember one columnist who was an
expert in this field
after yeltsin had made one of his trips
over here
derided him on the ground that he had
such poor table manners table manners
because he licked
caviar and butter off of his fingers at
a state dinner well let me tell you
yellston may not know what fork to use
at a state dinner but he has a very
sharp knife as i looked at the two
i realized that yeltsin was one who was
a political heavyweight and some of the
experts just couldn't see that because
they were blinded by style and couldn't
see the real man who was beneath
you uh you talk a lot about from time to
time in the book about intellectuals and
professors and here's another line from
this chapter on the soviet union um
you say here i i tend to agree with the
observation of 18th century european
king who said the cruelest way to punish
a province is to have it governed by
professors with notable exceptions such
as woodrow wilson great professors are
seldom good executives
that is true and incidentally i am one
who admires professors because
i admire them for their intelligence and
frankly i admire them for just doing the
job just teaching it must be a
tremendous ordeal these days
or at any time and i learned so much
from my professors but generally
speaking you will find that they are not
comfortable when they are in positions
where they have to make tough decisions
woodrow wilson is is
an example of one who was not only a
great professor but he was also a great
leader but he himself made a very famous
speech long before he became president
it was entitled men of thought and men
of action
and he said that generally the man of
thought is not a man of action the man
of action is not one of thought
wilson was both when you can find a
professor who can be a man of action as
wilson was in his first time first term
you have a very great leader
you did a book on leadership and leaders
who are your favorites
among the leaders among the leaders and
what do you look for in a leader
well when you talk about favorites i
think we have to separate
uh
whether you agree with them or not or
whether you disagree you have to i when
i look at leaders my test is did they
make a difference for better or for
worse and particularly of course for
better
and among the great leaders
uh well i could take off a number i had
the privilege of knowing churchill
when he was past his prime but but past
his prime he was ahead of almost any
other leader you could possibly know i
knew president eisenhower uh despite the
early evaluations of his presidency
which were negative he was without
question a great leader he said he
didn't know much about politics believe
me he knew a great deal and handled
himself extremely well
but let's leave out the americans and
look particularly abroad
i would rate de gaulle in that category
he was a great leader
i would rate
joe and lai in china
yoshida of japan
i think to adenauer and germany
de gaspri in italy
golda meir
in a smaller country israel
these were all great leaders magsaysay
in the philippines if they only had an
amag saisai today what a what he could
do for that country
these are all people who rose above the
level of events and as a result they
made a difference in their countries not
only for their own countries but for the
cause of peace in the world
you say how do you
rate joe and lie in that respect
johan lai was a communist
as was mao zedong but he was able to
reach above his ideology and do what
what was necessary to open a new
relationship with the united states
which helped his own country and in my
view in the long run will lead the china
after its economic reforms which are
succeeding to join the nation the world
of free nations
in the history of your career you have
been observed
probably as many words have been written
least by the contemporary writers
anybody in the country
you seem to enjoy
observing others and if you read your
books there's constantly little remarks
about how you have gone beyond just the
obvious
tall thin you know you look do you
observe people closely when you go when
you meet them yes i'm not one of those
who believes in the uh
psychiatric
examination of people you know
i believe that most of these people
these psycho historians should be on the
couch themselves rather than the
psychoanalyze people they've never met
on the other hand when i meet people
i don't judge them in terms of whether
they have a firm handshake or whether
they have eye contact
all of these things these are things you
learn things that you do things that
come naturally to you or if you don't
they don't come naturally you do it even
though they become unnatural but what i
try to do when i meet people is to
listen to what they say you don't learn
anything when you're talking you learn a
great deal when they are talking and
under the circumstances if you listen to
what they say and then evaluate
what they have been
you can reach some conclusions another
thing i do is this
i never take the views simply of
particularly when i traveled abroad of
the foreign service the state department
the cia they they had their views
but i try to get a broad spectrum of
views i believe in reading everything
about a person's background before i
ever met them then that way i could make
my own evaluation a little better
this is what the ninth book you've
written
yes it is the eighth since you left the
presidency the eight since i left the
presidency the first book i wrote was
six crises
uh and i must say that this book the
ninth was my ninth crisis writing a book
is very very hard work i know you
interview people on your program i've
seen them on occasion and i must say i
admire authors
i'm not saying that in terms of myself
but it is a great ordeal for me i don't
write easily
i
see you've got some yellow notes there
i mean notes on a yellow pad i write
outline after outline then i dictate
into a machine after i've done the whole
thing so that it is the spoken word
rather than the written word as you know
is very
formal
but uh and then i i have good people
that work with me
but when it when i finally get down to
to crafting the final product
it is a great great uh
burden or deal for me let me ask you the
same question every time i finish a book
i say never again
did you write this book
yes
i would say unfortunately those that uh
who who criticize the style and it
certainly justifies criticism
generally say that it sounds like me the
reason it sounds like me is that
after i take all of the and i i point
out that the authors note that i had
some excellent people working with me
uh marne stromecki who was the editor my
chief editor on this book who
made a great contribution
and monica crowley who's in my office
now joe marks
who
they were two full-time assistants then
a number of others wrote various papers
on the various subjects but when it
finally came down to the final product
then
i had to
not just do the editing
but i also had to get it in my words so
that it sounded like me as i often said
to
to people working with me
when i would rewrite something i'd say
the trouble is everybody knows my style
so well that if i leave it like this it
isn't going to sound like me i think
this book sounds like me for better or
for worse
let me just ask you about the title
sees the moment is this country in your
opinion seizing the moment
uh i think if i may be not partisan but
political to an extent which will not
surprise you
since you've covered the hill to an
extent
uh i think that the
the democratic candidates are missing an
opportunity here
uh missing an opportunity
in their criticism of
the incumbent president
of not seizing the moment
when i see them getting bogged down for
example bogged down in
in protectionism and bashing the
japanese and that sort of thing
i realize that
they aren't on the mount top for example
i know exactly what's going through
their minds
they read the polls which show that
foreign policy is of very little
interest to the american people today
and so they
virtually ignored it
and what they say about it is usually
wrong
now if they were really seizing the
moment they would look ahead
and they would take the american people
and the mountain people in the
mountaintop and point out that how
america leads what we do at home and
what we do abroad will determine whether
in the 21st century it will be a century
not of war as was the 20th century
uh but a century of peace the 21st
century will be a century uh not a
dictatorship but one of freedom and a
century not of poverty as was the 20th
century for most people in the world but
one of progress this can all happen
but it's going to require
that we
that we the inspire the american people
and not just limit the debate to
the to frankly very petty uh issues in
my view they are petty in some cases
let me ask you again about uh some of
the things you say and this
this pops up on every other page little
little uh
references to things
that i want to ask you about gorbachev
captures the elite in georgetown drawing
rooms yeltsin the workers at sverdlas
factory gates gorbachev appeals to the
head yeltsin to the heart gorbachev
dazzles a crowd yeltsin moves a crowd
the elite in georgetown drawing rooms
who are those folks and how much impact
do they have on the system here in the
united states well let me say i've i
know both georgetown and spurs loft i
visited spurs lost when i was there in
1959 when i had the so-called kitchen
debate with khrushchev and of course
i've been to many georgetown
dinner parties
georgetown is is of course where
people who have the money
live who can afford it because it is uh
it is a very
nice section of city it has all these
old homes and so forth these these
landmark homes
and a georgetown dinner party is one of
the most delightful things you can
possibly attend
but but it is a place if i may be very
direct where a lot of intellectual
incest goes on
uh
i think as you look at the beltway the
washington beltway it's it's what i
would call sort of the modern version of
plato's cave
we talk to each other and we think well
this is the world that we don't break
out and see what the world is really is
so
garbage off can dazzle that crowd
whereas
yelston is much more at home
out there at a factory gate
as
as garbachoff tried to be but he was
uncomfortable doing it
than
than would be the case with gorbachev
i would say too that uh
another point i would make with regard
to the two
i think this captures it better than
those phrases it's in the book i think
but it's this that
that gorbachev
was a man of the world
yellston was a man of the people
and a great mistake that yeltsin will
make is if he becomes so enamored with
this reception he gets as he travels
around the world that he becomes a man
of the world and doesn't contract con
spend his time as he should
on the problems of the people because
what happens in russia today is what is
important and he must not
as gorbachev did
not pay enough attention to the problems
at home in attempting to be a world
figure abroad and winning the nobel
peace prize
it was ironic that many americans
particularly within the foreign policy
elite viewed the new nationalists in the
soviet union with disdain or contempt
what is it about the i get the sense
that you the elite
and you don't get along or you don't
that you you have a
you say it yes you mention it so often
that well let me say that i it isn't
that i have anything uh
against the elite i mean i admire them
uh
if you want to spend an evening with the
group
go to a georgetown dinner party and the
rest but my point is that in terms
of seeing the real world
they are blinded too much by style and
frankly by by their own uh
prejudices and misconceptions
rather than opening their minds and
seeing the world as it really is
and by by the elite uh i don't mean to
put them down
they they are certainly superior to me i
would say most of them in an intellect
et cetera but insofar as knowing people
knowing what moves people
they simply aren't there they they
support a lot of losers
seize the moments this book america's
challenge in a one superpower world are
you happy with the way
the press has covered your book and
reviewed it and
just in general how this this thing's
going
well frankly i'm surprised i mean i'm
surprised because uh had a very
favorable favorable review in the new
york times
and also uh
was respectfully reviewed in the
washington post not particularly
favorable but it was respectfully
reviewed well reviewed generally
and i would say i am somewhat surprised
because
this is unconventional wisdom assuming
it's wisdom at all it's unconventional
because as you know it i take a
different view on the garbage off
yeltsin
matter i take a different view
on china
on mf man i take a different view
on uh
a number of issues particularly in the
last chapter on entitlements etc
and so under those circumstances well
the views that i express are probably
unpopular
i i appreciate the fact that most
reviewers at least appreciated the fact
that it was worth
reading it to see what i was thinking
uh this is really off the track but you
one of the times that as i was reading
that it got my attention where i i
thought that this was something new is
when you said that you were for strict
gun control yes
have you been for strict gun control oh
yes let me uh
let me be quite direct about that
i'm known as
a conservative republican and i am
conservative but on the other hand on
some issues i take a different point of
view
gun control
i feel strongly about it
i uh i have many friends joe foss who
served in with such distinction world
war ii i met him when i was in
in the pacific
he was a great fighter pilot 25
japanese plane shot down he's the head
of the organization but i am for strict
gun control you let's just look at the
figures during the persian gulf war
during that war
20 times as many people were murdered in
the united states as were killed in the
battlefield that's unacceptable gun
control i think could
have some positive effect as well in
controlling that and seeing that that
doesn't happen in the future
so in gun control i figure as you'll
note i take a different view on abortion
now that's a very sensitive issue
and americans may disagree about
abortion
but i feel very strongly that we should
not try to export our views on abortion
to countries abroad
i have visited
the
the countries what i call the southern
hemisphere i've seen
the overpopulation in those countries
i i know that
that the infant mortality everything
else is just
unacceptably high
under the circumstances population
control is absolutely necessary i don't
think we should subsidize it but on the
other hand i don't think we should say
that if a nation abroad does have an
abortion program we do not support a
population control program impor i think
for example the so-called mexico city
policy which the administration
apparently is endorsed
which would deny any assistance to a
population control program if the
country abroad has abortion i think
that's wrong
you also talk about the mt mtv
generation it sounds like you're worried
about the attention span of the young
people well uh we're on television so i
suppose i shouldn't knock it
but
i think it's very important that our
young people read more
i think they spend too much time in
front of the tube
i think that if they there's so many
good books out there that remain to be
read and to be reread
i like television
i've watched your program on occasion
i like sports on television i don't
write i don't usually listen to talk
shows
and i think that if that you can get
hooked on a lot of trash if you're on
television why don't you listen to talk
shows
the talk shows
have never appealed to me i've been on
them i mean i i go on one occasion meet
the press face the nation i've done them
all
but generally speaking i'd rather read
about it the next day rather than see it
i think that if you read it the next day
you
you're not going to be overwhelmed by
the style of whoever's on that show
it's very important to emphasize
substance rather than style how much
power do they have
great power oh
television
television has enormous power after all
i mean i'm sort of the expert in that i
was saved by television when i made my
fun speech in 1952.
people say i lost because of television
in 1960 in the debates with jack kennedy
in 1968 again i won with television and
my silent majority speech saved our
policy in vietnam so that we were able
to go ahead and finally reach a peace
agreement
just exactly 20 years ago
but i
but as far as television concerned it is
certainly a mixed blessing if it is a
blessing at all in politics
if we had had a television age
uh people like bob taft would probably
never been elected to the senate dick
russell one of the great senators would
probably never been elected to the
senate what i mean is the fact that
somebody's good on television
should not be the deciding
factor in determining whether he's going
to be
elected to public office
how do you
get your information today in other
words when you went to write the when
you decided to write this book you know
what's your daily habits of
intake on information well as i point
out in the book and as you're aware
first i traveled i've been this book
took if i may say
45 years to write
it began when i was a freshman
congressman when jack kennedy and i
supported the greek turkish aid program
which was the beginning of the marshall
plan
and which the goal of which was to
defeat the defeat of communism
and through the years i've traveled all
over the world i've had a chance to
survey the situation and what wisdom i
learned is in this book
not only traveling in office but while i
was as president and vice president but
also out of office
addition to that i talk to people
and i and i listen
because i find that talking to people
you can learn a lot in addition to that
i get most of my information
from reading i read i read newspapers
magazines
i read everything from the new republic
for example
to
national review the conservatives the
liberals etc
i read the columns
and i read as many books as i possibly
can
i don't i don't want to indicate
that i spent all of my time
reading material that doesn't eventually
end up in a book but i find
that only by expanding the mind by
reading and talking to people can you
then
write anything that makes any sense at
all
daily how many newspapers do you read
why limit that
uh because it's repetitive uh but i uh i
read in in new york where uh i'm living
newton in new york or near new york and
new jersey at park ridge i read the new
york times i read the wall street
journal
and then people send me and i have
somebody who sends me
the major columnists from other papers
from around the country and i don't i
just don't limit it to the times and the
journal
and for example the washington post the
washington times i find that some of the
best columns are written
out in the country and are not just the
big papers and the small papers
you go to the office every day
oh yes yes i go to the office every day
and i spend
about four hours in the office then in
the afternoon i read
generally
for about four hours and then
the rest of the time i try to write a
little the last time i saw that you're
79 years old
79 yes when's your 80th birthday
well it's too close it's a lot 11 months
from now
would you say that you have a happy life
and are you surprised that
based on all the things you've done in
your life that at where you are
well i'm uh oh yes yes but when you
speak of a happy life i i don't i don't
i'm not among those that think that
that when you judge a person
uh that uh or a life that the question
is are you having fun
that isn't the test the test is is it a
satisfying thing did you accomplish
something
and that is what gives you the
uh happiness in the broadest sense as
you have described it i reached an age
incidentally where i was rather
surprised when
i came in one of your associates out
here say my you uh you look very well
and i reached that age that dean russ
describes so well he describes the three
ages of man
and he said youth
middle age and my you're looking well
so under the circumstances i trust i do
as a matter of fact when i point out
that
i spend a lot of time in the office
i am doing what i didn't do in the white
house in the white house i played golf
only five times in five and a half years
and i had virtually no exercise
sometimes swimming when we went to
florida and
up to camp david in the pool but now
my sole exercise is walking i walk
between four to five miles a day about
two miles in the morning and two miles
at night that's what keeps me if i am in
good shape that keeps me in shape and
also some of the best ideas come when
you're walking
i found in talking to adenauer and de
gaulle
yoshida
de gaspri these great people i've had
the opportunity to know that many
virtually to a man they said
they got good ideas when walking by
themselves so i follow their example
you mentioned leaders are there any good
leaders or great leaders in the world
today
there's there probably are but we
probably don't recognize them
you see the difficulty is that when you
live among giants you don't realize that
they are giants
looking back i think i was fortunate of
course after world war ii i did meet all
the giants i met the giants i must say i
thought they were giants and you
couldn't meet churchill without knowing
you were meeting a giant or de gaulle or
adenauer yoshida or joe and lai or mao
satong and the others that i had the
privilege or here in the united states
people
that i've had the opportunity to know
like eisenhower johnson etc
but at the present time
we have a tendency to look around us and
say where are the giants and my my
answer is we won't know until maybe 25
years from now as a matter of fact i'll
put it another way
people are aware of the fact that i'm
sort of
a
connoisseur of good bordeaux
a bordeaux should never be drunk until
it's at least 20 years old in my view
history
is never worth reading until it's 50
years old it takes 50 years
before you're able to come back and
evaluate a man or a period of time so my
reading
goes back to
people
who lived and worked 50 years ago
as far as those who work today i'm not
going to evaluate them i won't be around
50 years from now to evaluate them
correct me if i'm wrong but i keep
hearing that
one of the reasons why thomas jefferson
is viewed as such a great man to dave is
because so much of what he wrote in his
papers have been
maintained and the reason why james
madison isn't thought of a lot by people
as much as thomas jefferson was because
a lot of his papers burned and they're
not around and i bring that up to ask
you about you've spent a lot of time
putting your thoughts down on paper are
you of the impression that this kind of
thing these books are going to last
they will last only if uh
if the events bear out
the predictions and also the
recommendations that i have set forth in
them
but whether they have lasting value is
something i cannot judge
the jury's still out on that
what i have tried to set forth in these
books that i have written
are
my
analysis of the way things were
but also to make recommendations
as to what our policy should be in the
future to avoid
some of the disasters we have
experienced in the past
i am probably wrong in many cases but in
other cases i can be right and if the
book affects this book affects maybe one
two even three potential leaders it will
be worth it
do you have any sense of whether any of
our leaders are reading this book right
now
well unless they're lying in the letters
they write to me i would say quite a few
are
but
brian we're not a nation of readers
anymore i know that uh
i know that the bookstores uh
they're at a recession at the moment uh
as is most of the country
but
unfortunately our our leaders today are
so busy doing things like members of the
house and senate they have to spend
their time raising money
meeting givers potential givers to their
campaigns and so forth
going to attending meetings just running
around like chickens with their head cut
off they don't have the time to sit down
and read
i would recommend that they take the
time and also what i would do is
i would urge all people who are in
public life who are trying to get into
it spend less time in front of this tube
even if you're listening to this program
and more time reading
if you were well based on what you the
18 years you've been out of office
looking back would you change the
presidency in any way well you had to go
back in there structurally what would
you do differently
well i'm not for the six year term i
think you need the two terms after all
the great accomplishments of most
presidents have been in their first
terms when they had to make a record
which would get them re-elected the
second terms have usually been
disastrous for most presidents but it's
been worth it woodrow wilson in his
first term was a great president
that's an example
now as far as the pr the office itself
is concerned the staff has grown much
too big
i think the white house staff should be
cut by at least 25 percent probably a
third and the same is true in all of the
agencies of the government
and it's particularly true of the
congress did you know for example today
because you you've spent a lot of time
in the hill
a congressman from california has a
bigger staff than i had for eight years
as vice president
and that doesn't make any sense does the
congressman do that much better than i
was able to do as vice president no
i think when you have a big staff
there's a tendency to leave too much to
step let me give you an example on books
one time i was talking to foster dulles
he had come back from a trip to europe
and he'd made a speech
and i was remarking that
i knew it was such hard work
to do speeches i said i was i was
complaining that i just hated to spend
all the time to write speeches and he
answered he said i like to write my own
speeches
it forces me to think the problems
through
he had a big staff at the state
department but he wrote his own speeches
and i would urge our congressmen our
senators our political leaders sure use
speech writers get good phrases in the
rest but you don't think the problem
through unless you sit down here with a
yellow pad and and write it out yourself
would you deal any differently with the
press
would i if you were president yes i
would have uh
if i had survived into the second term i
would have spent more time in press
conferences in the rest
it was very difficult in the first term
apart from the watergate period which of
course
answers itself but during the war
a president can't be as
as
available to the press as he otherwise
would be
but i think it's important with the
press that the relationship be
one of not trying to win them by having
them to dinners and all that sort of
thing they're not going to be bought off
by that kind of bribery
but the way to to deal with them is
straightforward and press conferences
address and don't play favorites i don't
think it's i think it's very important
not to play favorites well compare the
ronald reagan i think had something like
57 news conferences and george bush has
had
157 i mean just a whole different way of
looking at it but looking at the way
those two presidencies have worked with
the press
what's the good and the bad of it well
first everybody has to do it in the way
that fits him ronald reagan
was a great speaker
having press conference was not his
strong suit
george bush
is a good speaker but he himself would
say he's not a speaker like reagan
he is better in the give-and-take of a
press conference so he has far more of
them
my view is that with the press if i were
giving advice to
[Music]
people in office
particularly a president is
don't be too available because if you're
too available then when you have
something to say they're not going to
pay any attention they'll say ho hum
here it goes again
back to the book um
and if you were to characterize this
book for people who haven't seen it it
does cover the world that was your
intent yes
including the united states
uh
for the moment here and this is a
two-part series of of our two one-hour
discussions uh want to get back to a
country israel middle east
land for peace
you come down hard with the
recommendation
in israel
i do and uh some of my friends
who who are strong supporters of israel
as i am disagree with that i had a
letter from norman padaroth for example
who says he just disagrees with me on
this commentary magazine that's right
and a very uh very able
uh geopolitical thinker
i would say that as far as israel is
concerned what they have to realize is
that this is the best time in 40 years
to make a deal
because
the russians or the soviets as we used
to call them
aren't going to poison the well as they
have on all previous negotiations that
have taken place
uh the iraqis have been
certainly
put stopped dead in their tracks at
least for a while
uh the saudis are playing a more helpful
role uh arafat has been discredited to a
certain extent
when you make a deal is when you're
strong
i remember so well
de gaulle saying to me when i saw him in
1963
the united states
should open its negotiations and
recognize china now when china is weak
rather than waiting later
when china's strength will require it to
do so i followed that advice it was the
right decision despite what has happened
since then
i think as far as israel is concerned it
is in a very strong position now should
make its deal now now
what about land for peace
israel can't give up all the land
that it acquired in the 67 war it's got
to have secure borders
uh but to for israel to insist that it
must keep all this land is going to mean
that in the end
it will be sitting on an impossible
situation an impossible situation where
you're going to have millions of
second-class citizens there
who without question are going to
continue to cause difficulties
and which will make it very difficult
for israel to govern them without
getting international condemnation for
the way that they've done
you suggest that
israel is a socialist country
israel at the present time has a
socialist government
uh
it uh it by that i said
even though it's a conservative
government the labor party for example
which is in opposition to the current
government is is uh considered to be
more socialist than the than the current
one but what i am saying is this israel
i see
has the greatest potential of any
country in the world because of its
people
they have the highest literacy in the
world they they have the best scientific
capabilities of any people in the world
they have indicated all over the world
wherever they go
uh those who come from israel who have
the israel the jewish background are
among the ablest in the world now they
have to be unleashed
and israel
if it gets rid of some of this socialist
mentality which keeps the country back
there it can astonish the world and what
it will do it has already made a great
impression in the world it can do even
more
you come down
on the 1967 war on the side that israel
really started that war i mean there's
we we hear from our callers all the time
arguing back and forth explain your
position on that well as you'll note in
the book
i i point out that that is a view which
comes directly from israel because
that's something beggan himself said you
know he said after all he said we don't
know whether he was going to attack or
not but we did attack first
so the question of who did it first
however now is irrelevant
because you say that if we if they
started the war then we have a right to
keep the territory
i don't buy that either my point is
there isn't any question that israel
at that time felt it had to do what it
did because it was threatened by war
but now having acquired this territory
it must go back for example let me let
me use another example the united states
where this year we will celebrate the
20th anniversary of the reversion of
okinawa to japan
and yet japan started the war why don't
we keep okinawa because it's not in our
interest to do so it's better to have
okinawa which is [ __ ] was japanese under
under japan's control and as far as
israel is concerned israel's security
will be far better if it gives up some
land in order to have peace than it will
be if it tries to keep all of these
people repressed
and can and has to stay in a state of
war because israel
at the act for 45 years has been in a
state of war
israel needs peace and innocently about
half the people of israel are for
land for peace under a proper formula
you talk a lot about
by the way there's a lot of statistics
in this book where'd you get all those
statistics how did you accumulate them
all
a lot of us from my reading and a lot of
us from the excellent people i have on
my staff i'd have ideas and i'd say
check this check this check this and
that's not only those statistics have
been checked backwards and forwards and
i think they're pretty reliable that's
how you get them
one statistic is that we have spent
something like 400 billion dollars in 40
years on foreign aid
that that would include the foreign aid
which goes clear back to the the
marshall plan
and then
through the years uh
since then
and you say that the number the number
is astronomical
but
that of course includes
aid to uh
to countries that uh that receive
basically what we call security related
aid i'm aided to turkey aid to
uh pakistan etc
but you say that you're not too crazy
about foreign
as a matter of fact i during the
eisenhower years was the point man on
foreign aid i think it was the right
thing to do at that point what i mean is
that as far as our economic foreign aid
is concerned
that too much of it have been wasted
because it has gone to governments
rather than to people
and the governments have been corrupt
they have misused it they have been
either corrupt or socialist or whatever
in the future any aid we received has
got to find a way to get to people
rather than to go through governments
we spend something like 15 billion
dollars in foreign aid right now and 60
of it goes to israel and egypt bad idea
that is
one of the reasons why we ought to
be for a peace process that's frankly
not in our interest but it also is not
in israel's interest it's not an egypt's
interest
because
the the reason we're spending it is
because
egypt and israel had the peace process
the camp david of course for which
president carter deserves great credit
but now
we must have some sort of peace in the
area which would mean that much of those
funds could be released
for places in
africa latin america and so forth where
there are four billion people
uh living that's about four-fifths of
all the people in the earth
where 30 000 for example die each day
from drinking dirty water or from
contaminated sources
where in africa for example half the
people have malaria what i'm referring
to is this that i am for the aid israel
and egypt at the present time to carry
out the camp david accords
but it distorts america's pro-foreign
policy and in the future
it is very very important that we try to
find a way to get that in better
perspective so if we can have some sort
of peace settlement in the area and if
israel can move away from some of its
socialist policies
israel will then be much better off but
so will we and our we'll have a better
foreign policy
again a lot of our callers will call up
and talk to our guests and suggest the
only reason why we're giving so much
money to israel is because of the
israeli lobby how do you view that
i know that uh bashing the israeli lobby
seems to be a uh
a uh
problem these days
uh
let me say in that respect uh one of
those who's been uh
criticized for that is my old friend and
associate you know him well pat buchanan
now pat buchanan may say outrageous
things and he does
but when people say he's anti-semitic i
remember that in the
in the yom kippur war when i ordered a
huge airlift
which golda maier said saved israel that
the strongest supporter within the
administration for that airlift was pat
buchanan now anybody supported airlift
for israel is not anti-semitic
but i would say that looking at the
situation today
by the israeli lobby of course there's
an israeli lobby there's also an irish
lobby for northern ireland
there are a lot they're various lobbies
as we know they're lobbies for croatia i
hear from them when i wrote a recent
piece on croatia for poland etc
but what i am suggesting is that in this
instance
that
the fact that
we are supporting israel
is in our interest and in their interest
up to a point
but when it comes
as it does
to the occasion
when
it no longer serves israel's interest or
our interests then we've got to try to
support a peace process
that's why the peace process at the
present time must go forward i'm not
sure it will succeed but what i would
urge
to my friends
in the israeli community what i would
urge to them is
go into it with an open mind
find a way
to break this impasse because you just
can't continue to have a situation where
we're pouring all that money into the
israeli egyptian area which could be
used for other purposes of all the
places that you write about and all the
place you think about which part of the
world you enjoy the most studying and
thinking and
talking about
i've often asked what is my favorite
city in the world the city i would
prefer to go back to of all the places
i've been is istanbul it's the most
fascinating city in the world that does
doesn't put down paris it doesn't put
down london
uh it doesn't put down bangkok
or beijing and the rest but istanbul
here in the heart of the mideast i mean
the bridge to europe the bridge to
africa the bridge asia
that is one of the most fascinating of
all the countries of all the cities how
often have you been there
i've been there twice
and uh i hope to go one more time you
write in the book you've been to
russia or the soviet union seven times
with
i give equal time to both
have you ever total of the number of
countries in the world you've been to
well i think it's about 90 but uh
some of them are no longer countries
some of them were colonies at the time i
went there but it's it's it's in that
magnitude are you planning any more
trips
at the present time i don't have any
scheduled although i uh i have
been considering the possibility of one
more trip to asia maybe one more trip to
europe but i have none that i'm ready to
announce at the present time do you have
any other books planned
that i can answer categorically no
as i told you i remember when i finished
six crises i said never again never
again
and then
when i finished each book i would say
never again
my guess is that this is probably the
last but i'll still have some things to
say
i'll make a speech now and then
maybe appear on a television program now
and then
but only when i have something to say i
incidentally as you probably are aware i
i'm not on the speaking tour i don't
take honorariums
i only make a speech when i think as an
audience that needs to hear something
and the same will do is
i do the same with regard to what i
write
some years back you
also let go of your secret service
detail
why did you decide not to stay i don't
know how you phrased this on the
government dole on a lot of these things
and how much does the government pay of
your office space and all that stuff now
well the government takes care of the
office space and a staff of in my case
three people
uh four i should say
uh
four people the government takes care of
that and that they do that for all the
former presidents now the secret service
that's only purely personal all the
other former presidents have secret
service and the president's wives have
secret service if they think they need
it and they want it that's fine but it's
a matter of choice with a former
president and i decided seven years ago
and mrs nixon strongly supported in fact
she suggested it and recommended it that
we should dispense with it because i
don't think we need it and frankly we
like the privacy of traveling alone i
for example have come to down to
washington with one man who is uh
happens to be the
chief of police of upper saddle river
and he volunteered his time and i pay
some expenses for him and when i travel
abroad i take just one person with me
that's all we need because when you're
abroad the problem is you're usually too
safe they furnish all this for you
but and i should point out that as a
result
of getting rid of that secret service it
costs three million dollars a year to
support a former president and his wife
that it saved the taxpayers 20 billion
dollars i'm not suggesting now that
others must follow but that's a personal
decision of mine and i don't regret it
at all
how is mrs nixon
surprisingly well as you know she has
suffered and recovered from two strokes
you would never know she'd had a stroke
she now is she was able to go out to the
reagan library dedication and it was a
little hard for her she shouldn't have
really taken the trip but she said look
he came to our library i'm going to hers
and she's she's a very
strong
woman in that respect
and she
she does not do the public appearances
anymore but when it comes to babysitting
for grandchildren she is the best
we've got another hour to talk later but
i want to ask you before we wrap up this
hour in the beginning of the book
you have dedicated this book to the
democrats
i received incidentally a very outraged
letter
from a very good supporter who loved the
book and she says i love the book and
she agreed with me on my attitude toward
the russians and toward the chinese and
the rest but
she's a very partisan republican says
why did you dedicate it to the democrats
she didn't realize that it was a lower
case d rather than higher case this is
to the democrats of the world
and democracy
in the best sense
that is the wave of the future
in other words government by the people
rather than government from the top down
from authoritarian leaders be they on
the right or the left it's a way of
wrapping up this hour
i asked earlier
about your favorite place in the world
and really what i meant to ask you and
we'll pick it up in the next time uh is
what part of the world do you enjoy
thinking about and writing about where
we you know and you cover the world in
this book but what part
well
first
at the present time what happens in
russia is the most important thing let
me let me describe why that is so
important
because
yelston must not fail
historically speaking
it was about 170 years ago
the battle of waterloo was fought
and wellington after that battle
said it was a very close run thing
but
napoleon's defeat at waterloo
and wellington's victory
affected the course of history in europe
for a century the 19th century
today what happens in russia whether
freedom survives and wins
will affect the course of history for
the whole 20th 21st century
and if
he fails if russia reverts to
authoritarianism or dictatorship it
won't go back to communism but dictators
could be on the sidelines then it means
that the forces of freedom in the world
will have an enormous setback
take even china as china sees what
happens in russia
these tough hard-line leaders of china
at the present time would be delighted
to see yellowstone fail if he does not
fail the pressure then will be
irresistible on them that they too will
have to have political reforms to go
along with their economic reforms this
is what the book looks like it's called
seize the moment
the author is richard nixon
we talked a lot this hour about
russia we'll talk more about china and
vietnam and japan and germany in our
next hour thank you for joining us thank
you nice to be here
this weekend marks the 30th anniversary
of president nixon's resignation from
office
and now part two of it this hour about
russia we'll talk more about china and
vietnam and japan and germany in our
next hour thank you for joining us thank
you nice to be here
this weekend marks the 30th anniversary
of president nixon's resignation from
office
and now part two of his 1992 appearance
on book notes
former president richard nixon author of
seize the moment in the book
you write although president bush has
used the phrase new world order he does
not share this woolly headed idealism
why'd you write that
well the impression was
after the persian gulf war
that
president bush felt that that was really
a u.n operation
and that therefore we now were entering
a new era in which uh the united states
would no longer have to play the major
role or
but which where we could rely on the
united nations
to
deal with problems of that sort
they forget that as far as the u.n was
concerned he used the u.n he wasn't used
by the u.n it was very important to have
their support because without that
support he probably wouldn't have gotten
support of the congress
but the united states
must never be in a position
where it gives the un or any other
organization a veto over any actions
that affect its vital interests
and president bush is one who
understands that completely
he wants to have
a different world he wants to have a
world that's more peaceful but he is not
under the illusion that because we
defeated aggression in the persian gulf
and because as i put it in the book
communism committed suicide in the
soviet union now we have a new world
order and everything's going to be very
different where the united states can
reduce its
defenses far beyond the point that
would be
at least acceptable one of the things i
noticed through the book
and for those that are just watching
this when we had another session
together and so this is the second part
of the series um
is that you had a lot of references to
sports and i wrote a bunch of them down
and i wonder i want to read a couple of
them to you you said when you're talking
about japan you said in fact the
greatest cultural link between the two
countries is a common love of baseball
why did you write that
i wrote that because
between the united states and japan
there is a great cultural gap we are
very different and incidentally we
should honor the difference we should
not try to
change each other to become like the
other we like different food
we
like uh different dance for example and
that sort of thing
baseball however is one area where we
totally agree we like baseball
incidentally i look forward to the time
when japan will have major league
baseball it'll have the richest club and
i also want to say that i thought it was
a very serious
mistake
when the
baseball commissioner denied the
opportunity of a japanese group to
invest in the seattle mariners we should
welcome that if it makes the mariners
better so they're a contending team i'm
all for it
talk more about japan later um another
quote to put the east europeans up
against russia would be like fielding an
ivy league football team against the
washington redskins
well i think you should know brian brian
that that was a rather prophetic comment
because that was the book was finished
in september the 11th and at that time
the giants were still in it and i have
of course for the home team i'm for the
giants i used to be for the redskins
when i lived here
and i was in effect predicting that the
redskins were doing
uh
were going to do what they did do win
the super bowl then
i was glad it came out that way
but we have to understand that if you
put an ivy league team up against the
washington redstone at redskins it's no
contest and so it would be if you put
any of the eastern european countries up
against either the former soviet union
or the current
russian republic
another quote in 1991 for example the
city of denver paid more money for an
expansion baseball team than the united
states gave an aid to the people of
poland
as far as aid to the people of poland is
concerned i imagine that that had that
has more support than aid to a lot of
other areas because the polls
if we know their tragic history
have been overrun they have been divided
uh they have been repressed by the
russians on the one side and the germans
on the other and the austrians when the
austrians were still in the game
and so therefore there's a sentimental
feeling in favor of the poll
i think too
that uh
the
that when we we consider aid to poland
we are aiding a country we would be
aiding a country
that has gone that has taken the big
risk of having shock therapy they have
gone all the way to free markets
it's a very big risk it's very painful
for them they've had to go through
tremendous inflation and yet they're
seeing it through a country like that
deserves assistance
okay here's another we got two more uh
you're talking about mr gorbachev you
said he was at this point you wrote
about he's at the top of his game
addressing complex issues as
effortlessly as ozzie smith feels
grounders for the saint louis cardinals
well that shows that i do follow my
baseball i only wish ozzy smith were
we're with the mets or the yankees which
are my two home teams but he is the best
of course the best fielder uh he he is
uh not a great hitter although in one
world series as you know he did fairly
well a couple of years ago
and
he just basically mr smooth and may i
say gorbachev was mr smooth there is a
smooth character whereas i would say
that yelston is a very rough diamond
gorbachev is a very smooth diamond
all right the last sports uh analogy you
were talking about
a fellow by the name of nermee i believe
that's where you're pronouncing this sir
it is who ran in finland in 1924 in the
long distance running contest
and this is all about competition you
said had nermey faced strong competition
he would probably have broken the
four-minute
barrier 30 years before roger bannister
did in 1954. how did you know that
well i'm sort of a sports nut as you can
probably tell i i am that not because i
was any good at it i went out when i was
in high school in college for everything
for basketball football track never made
a letter always made the team
and i i was quite competitive but i
didn't have the weight or the speed or
frankly the brains to be the quarterback
so under the circumstances i followed
sports by reading about it and uh nermey
that was 1924. he was he ran in the
olympics that year i i was 11 years old
and i read about and i remember seeing a
picture in the los angeles times of this
runner as he turned the corner he was
looking down at his watch and the story
said that he was i think it was at that
time the 5 000 meter race as a matter of
fact he won the 1500 meter the 5 000
meter and the 10 000 meter probably the
greatest
distance runner who ever lived
and the reason was nobody could uh
provide competition as the rabbits do at
a dog track and said i don't bet the
dogs they're all fixed i understand but
whatever the case might be in the case
of nermey
he never broke four minutes in the mile
roger bannister of england he did break
four minutes the first one and now
virtually every great runner does and
that's because they have competition and
i use that example
to as a lesson to the those in this
country that want to close our borders
to immigrants
who want to close down
our markets to foreign goods
whenever a nation
goes down the line of protectionism
it is going into decline
a nation or a people to be great must
compete and compete with the best
otherwise we never break the barriers
whether it's the four-minute barrier or
whatever have you liked competing
well competition is i think you're sort
of born with it
uh
i i can answer it in two different ways
i don't
relish the battle the personal battle
of personalities
but the
the running for a post
the competing and a great cause
that to me has always been very
fascinating i like to read about it
uh i like to think about it and when the
occasion allows i'm i like to compete
but i particularly accidentally
think i do best when the odds are great
when the odds are great i think i do the
best
incidentally that's one of the great
strengths of president bush
you know he uh
he's known for his rhetoric and his
acceptance speech you know about a
kinder gentler policy tour and so forth
and so on
but and people underestimate him and
think well this is just a nice guy well
he is a nice guy and he's a fair guy but
he is a competitor
whenever the chips are down
don't figure that you're going to have a
pushover with him and he's always best
when he's behind that's why at the
present time when some of the polls
indicate that
he has a tough race or might even be
behind that's when he's most dangerous
they better watch out and he'll play
fair though
you quote a lot of different people and
and uh and i want to bring up some of
those quotes some of them are
ancient others are
closer to this time well i'm pretty
ancient so i guess that's why you do
that uh
you twice quote whitaker chambers
the first time
yokota was saying communism is never
stronger than the failure of others
faiths
and the second time you say that
whitaker chambers pointed out that the
war in korea was not just about korea
but also about japan what is it about
whitaker chamber is it you know why did
you go back and find quotes from him
well whitaker chambers
uh is only known as a former communist
spy who exposed alger hiss who had been
in the state department had been at
yalta with roosevelt
and who was convicted of perjury for
lying about whether or not he had
given documents to a soviet uh
uh
agent
uh
and chambers also was a great
writer he wrote some of the great
editorials for time magazine
he also wrote a great book witness which
i would recommend to anybody a
philosophical magazine
he was a very religious man a quaker as
a matter of fact a convert to quaker i
happen to be a quaker not a very good
one but we had them very much in common
there
and what he said there about communism
was very profound that he says it's
never stronger than
the failure of other faiths
and i said i wrote this as you'll note
in the context of the muslims the
muslims have a strong faith whatever we
want to think of them and some of some
of the
the those extremists who have engaged in
some of these terrible acts
the those who have the muslim religion
have not been
usually very susceptible to the
communist appeal whereas in christianity
many christians have been it doesn't
prove that muslims are better than
christians or vice versa it does tell us
something though about the strength of
the faith
uh i think too that in chamber's case he
understood the world he had been a
communist but he became a communist
because he wanted to change the world
and as a communist he and an
intellectual uh he had he understood the
world and when the reason that he said
this about korea
he was not for not for eisenhower i was
for eisenhower
he actually was for taft and he was very
sad when taft came out against aid for
korea this is when the communists
attacked the north vietnam north
koreans attacked south korea and he said
what the senator does not understand is
that the war in korea is not about korea
it is about japan because if they get
south korea then they will have a dagger
pointed at japan and japan being very
weak then immediately after world war ii
would fall under their laps
that to me was geopolitical thinking at
its very best do you ever go back and
think about the days that you knew
whitaker chambers and the alger his case
and all that that was one of your
as a freshman congressman was one of
your first uh
you know when he first became visible on
the national scene that's right
uh
well it was a uh it was quite an
experience for a freshman congressman
and that was the time when we didn't
have the huge stash this will be hard to
believe but i was only the only lawyer
on the unamerican activities committee
which investigated that case
we had no lawyers on our staff it was a
staff of only five people we had a
brilliant chief investigator bob
stripling
who was really better than a lawyer
and
yet we were able to uh to
expose his for what he really was he had
lied about he said he didn't know
chambers and he had lied with regard to
turning over uh documents to
a communist agent a soviet agent
and yet we were able to do that
when we were up against the justice
department the administration up against
one of the greatest law firms of the
country with scores and scores of people
i guess what i'm coming around to here
you don't need huge staffs
such as the staff that have investigated
the iran contra thing in order to do a
good job of investigation
smaller staff overworked does far better
than a huge staff where a lot of people
are using are you
spending most of their time cutting each
other up
other
quotes here franz kafka
every revolution evaporates leaving
behind only the slime of bureaucracy
why'd you use that
i used that because it was very
important to point out that
we that at this time as the soviet union
and now russia and the various other
republican republics
throw off
communism
there has still left the bureaucracy
who ran the place you of course had the
top people but you also had all these
thousands millions of bureaucrats
and
if you have those bureaucrats there
that's the slime of bureaucracy if you
have them there
then when you try to run the place for
example the problem that yellston has in
having a free market economy who's going
to implement it who are going to run the
factories and the rest
so there have to be trained a whole new
group of managers and that's
that's the area where the united states
and the west needs to concentrate
particularly in providing assistance to
russia and the other former soviet
republics
we must provide we must help them
develop a management class
rather than a peace corps for example
and it can be helpful in some areas and
rather than a democracy car what we need
is
an enterprise
core
where the best young management types
from the best of uh
corporations big book corporations this
country and in other countries abroad
are sent to russia and the other
republics where they want to accept them
and help them develop a new management
class so that this slime of bureaucracy
can be pushed away because they are not
going to support
they are only going to sabotage a free
market program what memories do you have
of your own bureaucracy when you were
president
i have memories of some very able people
for example i i
take a few shots here at some of the
foreign service people who have briefed
me in the past where i didn't think the
briefing i thought it was honest they
thought it was honest but it didn't
prove to be correct
because they were substituted they were
confusing style with substance
uh but generally speaking
i found that if you want something done
you've got to do it in spite of the
bureaucracy and not through them but if
you lead them if you lead them then they
are professionals but on the other hand
those that say
well the secretary of commerce the
secretary of state or the secretary of
the treasury should simply ask the
people in the bureaucracy to develop a
program forget it it's not going to come
leadership has to come from the top it
has to come from the secretary himself
or in the case of the administration on
the national policy it has to come from
the president if it doesn't come from
there it will not come up from the
bureaucracy although those in the
bureaucracy can be
very very effective in implementing a
policy once they know what is to be done
it isn't a question of their being
disloyal
they're not disloyal to the country
they're not disloyal to the to their
president but his point is that they
simply don't have the capability they
have never developed it to lead they
expect the leadership to come from
somewhere else
uh andre melro you quoted
him as saying he he said once he
observed the us is the only nation in
the world to have become a world power
without intending or trying to do so
he was a legendary figure as you know in
in literature
i met him for the first time de gaulle
introduced me to him when i was there in
1969 on the state visit my first state
visit to france
and then he came to the united states
and i saw him
and i gave a small dinner for him just
before going to china
and
at that time he had had a stroke and he
he talked very painfully just as mao had
had a stroke he had been in china as you
know
and was an expert in that field and he
was very
frankly complementary of the fact that i
was
going to china i remember as he was
leaving that day he went out on the
south portico and he said to me speaking
painfully through his
rather contorted mouth he said mr
president i am not de gaulle
nobody's the gaul but if de gaulle were
here
he would praise you for what you were
doing
mauro of course was a great historian he
was a great writer and that statement is
right on target because as distinguished
from other powers that became world
powers
the united states did not try to do so
in fact we did not want to do so after
world war ii we would have all brought
all the boys home and we wanted to do
that and not played a world role
except for the fact there was no one
left to do it
the british and the french
the italians and the rest were all
decimated by war they couldn't do it and
of course the others who might have done
it among the great powers the japanese
and the germans were defeated so the
united states had to be the leader but
we became the leader
of the free world because we were the
only ones that could lead
and we did it not however as
philanthropy but for ourselves because
if we don't lead who else is going to
lead the day
people say well let's let somebody else
do it we've taken the burden the only
other nations capable of leading today
who have the resources in the
to do so
potentially are the japanese
the chinese
the russians
and the germans does anybody want to
leave their fate in the hands of those
nations and those peoples no so the
united states right now whether we want
it or not despite all the isolationist
talk we must lead if anybody if we're
going to build this
new
world call it order or whatever you want
to call it why wouldn't you want to
leave your fate to the germans
because i i do not believe that the
germans frankly would accept that
responsibility
uh i do not have the feeling that many
have that because the germans uh were
engaged in two world wars and many
believe were certainly aggressors in the
second and many believe were aggressors
in the first although some questioned
that
there were many at fault i am not i
don't beli agree with those that say
that the germans are just
they're going to be an expansionist
power
always after 45 years of democracy i
trust the germans but i would also say
that it's not true of many of their
neighbors they still have memories of
the germans riding through their
capitals and tanks rather than mercedes
limousines as is the case today
and so the germans are not the ones to
lead
they have they have a history which will
not let them to lead and the same is
true the japanese the japanese are an
economic superpower but does somebody
want the japanese to lead the day what
about the chinese
same story the chinese
would not be ones that we would want to
be the leaders of the free world if you
were in that white house today what
would you do with the japanese
well we've probably even on an hour's
program couldn't cover that completely
but
let me say that uh
i'm going to say something that may
surprise you those that bash japan are
running america down
and why do i say that
because
we should
welcome the fact that japan is a
competitor they've got to compete more
fairly than they do we've got to insist
on that and their tariff barriers must
come down the other non-tariff barriers
which are the major ones that they have
but on the other hand we've got to
realize that we share so much in common
they are a democracy we are democracy
they are for free markets we are they
have no expansionist goals we have no
expansionist goals between the two of us
we have 40 of the gnp of the world
between the two of us
we can play an enormous role in seeing
that the world remains free
after for example europe becomes
protectionist as it may after 1992
then japan and america must stand
together to keep the world open the
other point i should make that with
regard to japan
uh
we shouldn't be so concerned about the
fact that they are investing in america
that's good uh
you have in mind the fact that
the british have twice as much invested
in america as do the japanese and the
dutch have almost as much
another point i should make is that
japan
is uh that they're very good
but we are better in many areas and we
can stay ahead our productivity strange
enough is higher than that of japan our
worker productivity we've got to make it
better of course
another point i would make just in
conclusion on that particular point
is that
i remember immediately before world war
ii you're too young to remember this but
before world war ii there were those
that said we don't need to fear the
japanese they can't shoot straight
because their eyes are slit eyes well
they sunk them you the pacific fleet of
pearl harbor and we learned they could
shoot straight today we go to the other
extreme we think they're 10 feet tall
that we can't compete with them and that
we therefore have got insist on programs
by american boycott japanese and so
forth they've got problems their
population is getting too old you know
at a time for example at the united
states
and some of our governors
are necessarily trying to cut back on
welfare
to uh mothers who have a third or fourth
child or whatever the japanese provide a
bonus of sixty five hundred dollars a
year to any woman that has a third child
because their population is getting old
second point their young people want the
good things of life now as ours do and
that means that they're not going to be
able to
compete as ruthless as they have done
previously but third and this is
probably most important
they're missing an opportunity that we
are not missing
40 percent of japanese women are in the
workforce but they are second-class
citizens throughout in that workforce
the fact that we have raised women as
much as we have is a great asset for us
and the japanese have so much to learn
so that in the end
this competition will be good for both
but i think rather than bashing the
japanese we should try to do better
welcome the competition and do better
than they can and i think we can
by the way in your book you give credit
to a lot of people in the back that
helped you but there were several names
i wanted to ask you about because you
mentioned other people who used to work
with you bob ellsworth dimitri simes
ray price how did these folks help you
write this book
bob ellsworth uh
went with me on my trip
to uh the soviet union and he has
traveled with me on other trips before i
was president
and he has written me memoranda for many
many years and we often talk he used to
work for you that's right
he was in our administration he was
ambassador nato uh
one of the top geopolitical thinkers in
the country and in the world for that
matter
uh dimitri symes also was with me he was
the one that was responsible for my trip
to the soviet union in march but we've
been very close for several years
because we i've written i read his
columns and we share views and he's been
an advisor on those
those matters
and
so i used a lot of
his thoughts in developing
my
my soviet chapter particularly
ray price was particularly helpful in
the last chapter of the book he worked
with me of course earlier on the real
war and on leaders
he was my top speech writer as you know
head of the speech writing team in the
white house
and in the field of domestic affairs
where he is truly expert he's very good
in foreign affairs is ready he was
absolutely invaluable many of the best
ideas in the last chapter are are from
ray price after long talks with him you
also mentioned james billington who's
current librarian of congress hey
james billington is of course i you
mentioned intellectuals now there is an
intellectual to show you i i have an
open mind who everybody ought to get
ought to know better he has a
first-class geopolitical mind he
particularly is expert in soviet affairs
i'd like to see him sometime i'd like to
see him ambassador russia i think he
would be a great ambassador
got some more quotes in here i want to
read but i want to ask you about another
thing that you mentioned you talk about
mass media and pop culture
and you mentioned television shows
dallas knott's landing and dynasty and
you suggest they paint an
unrealistically glamorous picture of
america as exports around the world
these these are seen in other countries
well first i don't see them very often
but i see parts of them
and what i see is not the america that i
know
uh i i don't want our shows abroad to
show just the worst side of america but
i think it should be more balanced we
mustn't leave the impression
that everybody's running around in
limousines and and uh you know living
high on the hog and so forth
we i i want to make clear here
america is the place to go it's the
place to be
uh we stopped to think of it with all
this running down of america these days
and saying well we can't do this and
that the traffic's all one way
i used to have my office in the
federal building in new york and they
have the offices there for people that
want to
you know get passports and that sort of
thing and those lined up to get out of
america there were very few i mean to
move primarily those lined up to get in
went clear around the block people want
to come here because it is a country
that offers opportunity for all with all
of the problems that we have
let me read you another quote
from your book you wrote this
many liberals
who claim to be advocates of the
underdeveloped world
raised the banner of protectionism in
their campaigns against the free trade
agreement
though their hidden agenda seeks to
shelter special interests they have
launched
a two-pronged attack against the free
trade
accord
what what hidden agenda of special
interests are you talking about well
what we're talking about is the hidden
agenda
of
of industries steel is one some parts of
agriculture others
where
they simply want to have a market
where they have a monopoly they don't
want the foreign competition let me give
you an example of how it affects the
the in the agriculture field how did it
affects the people listening to this
program or the great majority of the
american people
uh
due to restrictions of that sort on
agriculture because we're trying to keep
some people in business who are no
longer competitive and aren't that do
the restrictions i was just reading
recently
in a column in newsweek these facts
at the present time
uh americans
can have only one teaspoon full of
foreign ice cream a year
they can eat only two foreign grown
peanuts a year
and uh
they can eat only one pound of foreign
produced cheese a year now that's
nonsense due to those restrictions we
pay twice the world price for sugar
why because we want to protect sugar
growers we want to protect 15 000 uh
peanut growers or 30 000 whatever the
case might be that doesn't make sense i
don't want to put them all out but what
out of business but i do say
that when it comes to that kind of
protection that doesn't make sense and
in the case of steel for example
our steel makers can eventually compete
but simply putting up these artificial
restrictions means that they're not
going to do so because people only
compete if they have to
and i think it's very important for us
to
make it necessary if we're going to be
the best
we must have the competition from the
best that's why i'm a free trader up and
down the line
richard nixon quote advocates of the
cradle-to-grave welfare state and of
socialism with a human face
still carry clout at the elitist dinner
parties in washington we talked about
the elitist and the other program i want
to give you a chance to
continue what what you have here is a
situation where which comes
pretty much from the uh from
what i would call the the university
community
uh
there are
a number of
of very fine teachers
who basically uh
are enamored still with with with marx's
thought they are not communist you
understand but you know
this is a theory they they they're for
equality and
therefore changing the world and so
forth in that direction
now as a result of the of the
that because communism committed suicide
at least in the soviet union or in
russia
the number who openly would do that is
reduced but at the present time there is
still
there is still
in what i would call the
the the intellectual community in this
country
many of them are enamored with the idea
of uh
of equality at any cost uh
call it socialist ideas they would
reject that term but that's exactly what
it is
what they what they want to do is to
look to government to solve problems
rather than to people to solve problems
they look down their noses at houses at
business people at individual enterprise
private markets and the like and frankly
time has passed them by it's time for
them to recognize as even the swedes
have recognized
we know that communism doesn't work that
socialism at its best doesn't work and
it's time when the rest of the world is
turning our way
for us not to turn
the way that they were
if you had to do it all over again and
and go to school
go to college
you got a law degree from duke uh i
believe it's is it duke yes sir remember
right uh would you play a basketball
team would you do it the same again
i think i was very fortunate in my
college days i i went to a small college
and i'm four small colleges and the
large ones as well of course because
they
each has to
make its own contribution my small
college is footier in california
and uh used to be quaker school that is
now non-sectarian
i never had a course in political
science they didn't teach it
i don't think i lost much
you learn more about political science
by practicing it than you do by hearing
it about it or reading it in the
textbook
at duke i was very fortunate the law
school at duke was was a great school
when i was there
the classes were small and we had some
great professors like lon fuller who uh
one of the top legal philosophers in the
country whom i quote in my book
incidentally
uh and i think i i wouldn't change it no
i like the fact that i went to
undergraduate school at a small school
and then went to a top flight graduate
school where the competition was as high
as it could be
what is most important is that an
individual who wants to develop to the
all of his abilities you can't do it
unless you are have to compete and so
at the graduate level be sure you pick a
school where it's where you're going to
have real competition
it's tough
but it's worth doing if you can't make
it there you're not going to make it
elsewhere
also from your book though about the
academic environment the image of the
united states this is you writing the
image of the united states as a
declining great power remains dear to
the hearts and minds of many academics
having said that and what your attitude
about a lot of academics how do you if
you were again starting over again how
do you protect yourself against
the so-called
marxists and the universities well the
difficulty is with with many of our
academics
and it's incidentally a tribute to our
younger people that so many of them come
out without being brainwashed
they come out in fact they re they they
react the other way some of them turn to
the conservative line
the
you find in in many of our so-called
better schools uh this idea that
that the united states is a declining
power
they see everything that is wrong with
the united states and there are many
things that are wrong
but they fail to take into account
that there are many things that are very
admirable about the united states and
they also fail to see the real world if
the united states does not lead who
i mean i i don't buy this business well
the united states is not worthy to lead
because we have so many problems at home
yes we've got problems
but let's solve those problems but let's
not retreat into isolationism and
beating our breasts about how bad we are
when there's so much in this country
that is good i don't speak as a
jingoistic individual who sees nothing
to be improved in this country i have
some pretty tough comments in here about
what we can do to improve but let's quit
running america down and try to make
america better what period of your life
did you enjoy the most
well these personal questions are very
difficult for me because i i don't like
to psychoanalyze myself but if let me
try to answer it objectively
i liked all periods in this way i mean
i went to college in the depression and
it was rough
it was rough but uh we didn't even think
of it as a depression i mean we
we had to scratch around
to to make a living to have anything i
can remember when
getting a steak was considered to be uh
something that was so unusual that we
we just thought
this is a this is the ultimate as far as
a fine food and so forth is concerned
uh all of that has changed uh i uh
i would say that i i like my my uh study
of the law
uh at duke due to the fact that i had
great teachers
the practice of law was not something
that i
that i liked as well as some of the
other things i did
although i was very fortunate to have
outstanding partners i mean the partners
that i had in new york law firm were
really
not only not only good lawyers but they
were fine people
they talk about what new york lawyers
some of them are very fine citizens and
in addition to being fine lawyers but i
would say that
the most interesting time in my life has
been
in running for office serving in office
uh the years out of office however
the years in the wilderness as i call it
between the loss of 1960 and winning the
president in 68
while it wasn't i wouldn't say it was my
favorite time it was probably my most
useful time
that's when i was able really to travel
the world to learn what really made the
world tick and to develop my thinking so
that i could be
perhaps a better president than i would
have been had i been elected in 1960 had
i been elected in 60 i wouldn't have had
the opening to china
but when i was elected in 68 i was ready
to make that move
so that was why that was important and
now of course i
uh i this is the period after having
been in office
uh the we had some difficult times in in
offices everybody knows
uh not speaking just of watergate but
presiding as president over a war that
was terribly divisive was not easy
uh but the period since then
has been uh
uh
while an ordeal
yet
it has its compensations because in a
period when you're down
you then discover who your real friends
are
and i have some great friends out there
i hear from them by mail some of them
come to see me
and when i think of people being for me
at a time when most of your friends in
the media are against me which is not
unusual they always have been as i
understand it uh it's really very
reassuring did you ever
ask yourself why so many in the media
are against you
oh they didn't agree with what i stood
for so this is long before watergate
the his case particularly was very
difficult for the media they all thought
he was innocent and if they didn't think
he was innocent they didn't want him
uh exposed because it as
one individual said he said it would be
a reflection on the uh on the foreign
policy the
of the roosevelt administration which of
course was not my goal at all
and so with that it was difficult not
that i didn't have
many friends in the media but
media people
while they try to be objective many of
them do
they also have strong convictions
and
frankly
they are
they generally are not particularly
enamored with the conservatives
as i am
even though i am probably more
reasonable than some of the
conservatives that they go after
somebody else i mean i
assume you studied the way people even
treat you now
people often say you're a contradiction
they write it all the time this
great success in foreign policy and
but the difficulties you had in your
presidency alone how do you address that
the contradictions in richard nixon or
do you think about it
well i really don't think about it but
since you asked the question i would say
that that's uh that's part of a
political life
i have
i have read a lot as you know
i repeat what i said in our first
interview that
i
don't consider history ripe
until it's 50 years old so i read a lot
about the 19th century and early earlier
periods in which democracies began to
develop in
britain and the united states and so
forth
and
you find that leaders in democratic
countries are generally
not universally liked all the time
they they they are very effective in
some areas not as ineffective in other
areas
in my case
i was considered to be by most
somewhat effective in foreign policy
although many disagreed with me on
the fact that i insisted on
trying to win peace with honor in
vietnam
uh
on the other hand
they uh felt that uh politically that uh
i was uh not the kind of a leader that
they liked and i understand for example
in the watergate period that that would
certainly be justified but it wasn't
just that it was in other areas as well
as you're well aware
what about watergate and vietnam what
are the
you know
those two periods uh difficult as they
were for the country what's the legacy
of that
those periods and uh
you see any in the youth
well
the legacy of watergate
i mean and vietnam fortunately now is
pastors the syndrome is over
and it was particularly see vietnam more
than watergate
uh vietnam
has been
described by many
who
are are frankly not not really aware of
what happened or if they are aware
they're they're not properly disclosing
it
vietnam was not a military defeat for
the united states
every american had left vietnam two
years before it fell
and it fell because the congress didn't
provide the assistance to the south
vietnamese that were our allies that the
soviets and the chinese were providing
to the north vietnamese
but it was an enormous defeat for the
american spirit because a country that
we had supported
two years after we had left
it came under communist domination
and so right after vietnam
the general
conventional wisdom in this country was
that the united states couldn't do
anything well because we had lost in
vietnam to this third
world
power
uh that was wrong
just as it was wrong to assume
after we had won in the persian gulf
that we we could do anything
after vietnam we could do nothing and
after we
won in the gulf we could do anything and
then of course to carry the syndrome a
little further after the collapse of
communism
in russia and eastern europe there's
nothing left to do
these are all instant evaluations which
are incorrect the world remains the same
the united states still
could play a major role after vietnam
because we had not suffered a military
defeat
and we should have played the role
for a while we did not
and it cost us dearly
and the same is true with regard to
these other areas at the present time to
say that because communism is collapsed
in the the former soviet union that
there's nothing left to do that assumes
that that's all the problems we had let
me just give you one example
people will be surprised by this but
since the end of world war ii there have
been 140 wars
eight million more people have been
killed in those wars than were killed in
all of world war one which used to be
called the big one
most of those wars would have been
fought had there been no conflict
between the soviet union and the free
world and the united states
now that has not changed that is why the
united states must continue
to maintain adequate military forces
because what happened in the gulf
affecting our vital interests can happen
in other places as well
back to a couple of quotes saint thomas
aquinas
if the highest aim of a captain were to
preserve his ship he would keep it in
port forever
that quote incidentally came from
a book by lon fuller lon fuller
uh my professor at duke university
gave a series of of lectures at yale
and that was a i in reading that i found
the quote i would like to say that i
read everything that saint thomas
aquinas had written but i didn't i got
it out of there
and i think it's a marvelous quote
because what he is what the quote tells
us that seven centuries ago
that
an individual
must not be satisfied with just keeping
what he has many conservatives
make the mistake of saying what we're
going to have to do is to keep what we
have we mustn't risk anything
in order to be better or to improve
and as you point out
if you if the whole the sole purpose of
a leader or of an individual is to
retain what he has
uh then
that's the same as uh keeping a boat in
in
because of your uh
unwillingness to take it to sea
in other when you take that boat out to
sea it's true you're going to run into
rough weather sometimes
sometimes it may even be sunk
but if
what you do is simply keep it in the
harbor forever because of your fear
of what the world out there holds then
you're not going to be what you really
should and can be
working up to the limit of your
capabilities you told us in our first
hour that
if you had to pick a city you'd go back
to where you liked the most would be
istanbul
if you had to pick a book
a book that you
enjoy reading the most maybe reading it
again you say you'd like to go back and
read them over again what would that
book be
well i would answer and i can say this
in a way that it doesn't certainly
appear to be political uh you would have
to say take the bible for that i mean
the bible apart from religion is great
literature
the new testament particularly and even
parts of the old testament i've always
felt that the book of ecclesiastes for
example was some of the most eloquent
writing
uh that
that i've ever seen and it's uh
it always lifts you
so i would i would pick that as a book
now
among others
very hard to tell among current authors
that i read who write historically i
would say
the books by paul johnson appealed to me
a great deal he's a he's a marvelous
writer he's a geopolitical thinker
uh
the
and many people of course remember his
later books but the one that is my
favorite is is one on the british the
offshore islanders it's just a marvelous
book it's it's not only great prose it's
great poetry as well
if you have to pick music that you want
to listen to the most what would you do
uh not vocal music i'm uh i'm not one
who goes much for opera perhaps because
i don't like the uh the social part of
opera you know i've been invited many
times and supposed to dress up and you
go to the dinners and all that sort of
thing
uh
i uh
i think that i would prefer the the
tchaikovsky
ballets i don't like ballet particularly
but and i've seen swan lake a number of
times i've seen it believe it or not
i've seen swan lake in moscow i've seen
it in leningrad i sent it in spurs lost
i have seen it also in nova scotia and
all of them with great companies but if
if i had to turn on
a record i would like that
some of the tchaikovsky
ballets and so forth
and i like liszt i know that somebody
was saying to me once when i wanted some
number the lids preludes played at one
of our
inaugurations the leader of the
orchestra didn't want to play it because
he said hitler liked it oh my goodness
the fact that hitler may have liked the
music doesn't mean that
i that i liked it because he did
lists preludes has a moving quality to
it that i like to play and then i would
say if you want to get to modern music
uh
i think the guadal the guadalcanal
guadacanal march
in victory at sea that has a lift to it
that is really incredible
uh who in history
that you would you like to meet that you
have not met
possibly because you didn't
get a chance to see them or they're
deceased
either who would you like to be if you
had your first choice or second choice
of a couple people you'd like to spend
some time with spend some time with that
you'd never had a chance to know
well i was fortunate to know some of the
great people in history uh looking
further back
well looking at british history
particularly
this will surprise our audience i
suppose
look at the 19th century and i've
studied that considerably
who were the great british prime
ministers if you asked
most of our scholars out there they
would of course name pitt at the
beginning of the century
and many would name gladstone and many
would named israeli to me the greatest
british prime minister was probably peel
and the reason peele was a great prime
minister
was that he was responsible for the
repeal of the corn laws
now because he was for that uh the
repeal of the current cornwall's
uh corn laws
uh peale lost office and his party was
split apart the the tory party and he
later died and falling off his horse
incidentally unfortunately in an
accident in hyde park
now why do i why do i like peel and
admire him
because he took an unpopular position
which was the corn laws
which uh was against the uh
the
what many of his constituents the
farmers and so forth of britain wanted
and he supported that position and as a
result britain gained enormously from it
they got cheaper grain and it enabled
them to move forward in the industrial
revolution is because britain became
then a free trading nation to the extent
that you could become one so i i give
peel the highest marks for making a
difference for most of the people even
though it cost him enormously
politically
you have a quote in your book goes back
to the iron curtain speech made at
westminster college in fulton missouri
in 1947.
the u.s stands this is winston churchill
the u.s stands at this time at the
pinnacle of world power
it is a solemn moment for the american
democracy
for with primacy and power is also
joined an awe-inspiring accountability
for the future
why'd you use that
i i used that uh quote
for this reason you you earlier asked me
about melro
when he said that uh the united states
is one of those nations that became a
world power without trying to do so
the american people basically
are isolationists
we like our country
we we like to travel abroad
but we we don't want anything from any
other country
we don't want to expand
uh we don't want to have our young men
and women to have to risk their lives in
foreign wars and that sort of thing
and yet
at the present time we can't think that
way any longer
wendell wilke wrote a book many years
ago called one world it was a very short
book
it wasn't one world then when he took
that trip around the world but it is now
because of the communications explosion
we all live in one world a day
let's put it in terms of
present-day politics people talk about
why don't we talk about
the
the needs of our own people
we have a recession and all that sort of
thing
do you realize
that as far as the united states is
concerned
that
approximately 20 percent of our gnp at
the present time comes from world trade
if we if the rest of the world
has a sick economy we're going to catch
the sickness as well
let me take it back a few years
we all have read about and i lived
through the great depression
it was first a recession
it became a depression
when the world economy collapsed in part
because the united states adopted the
smoot-hawley tariff act
we mustn't let that happen again at the
present time what happens in faraway
places in europe in japan
in russia and so forth can have a
dramatic effect on the united states if
we want a healthy american economy we
can't do it alone anymore because a 15
or 20 percent drop because of trade
being cut off would bring a disastrous
depression here
we are
shortly going to be out of time i want
to ask you are you surprised
about how people treat you today and
what i mean by that is
just take your visit here and
you can't walk outside here the camera's
waiting for you and the people surround
you they want your autograph are you
surprised after being out of the white
house since 1974 and what you went
through that people are
approaching you the way they do
well people are
the american people are
sometimes for the underdog and maybe i'm
gaining a little from that
and also the american people like
so-called celebrities
celebrities
whether they're celebrities for good
reasons or bad reasons
and maybe i'm a benefit from that
but
i i would say to me
what is
what means the most is when somebody
came up to me comes up to me as one did
just recently just today
said
he was a little bit older he was ill
younger than you are
and he said i just want to thank you he
said because of what you did i got home
from vietnam
and so that makes it all worthwhile
if you
had to choose another profession that
you haven't done that you've observed
over the years and we want to give a try
at it what would it be
sportscaster
i think that would be the greatest job
in the world
i like sports
i think i would do it pretty well
because i like to i like to watch how
they play and see these young people how
they meet the tests and so forth
i just love to be a sportscaster why do
so many politicians and
political columnists talk about sports
because many of them have come up that
way you know you take
among the writers scotty reston for
example was a sports writer peggler was
a sports writer i've taken two extremes
there who probably couldn't get along
with each other but nevertheless they
both like sports and the reason is
that politics is the greatest sport
there is
it's competitive
people win people lose people come back
etc
so i think that's the reason that you
see an affinity between the politicians
and sports writers
the name of the book is called seize the
moment
our guest has been richard nixon former
president united states
thank you for joining us thank you
enjoyed being with you again
richard nixon was the 37th president of
the united states he served two terms
and then resigned 30 years ago on august
9th
his other books include 1999 victory
without war and beyond peace
president nixon passed away on april
22nd 1994.
maureen dowd was the